l'hécatombe de la nuit dernière sur
l'autoroute près de beaune 53 morts dont
44 enfants originaire de creil et de
crépy en valois mis sur pied d'une
commission denquête et ouverture demain
d'une information judiciaire
liban nouveau cessez-le-feu à beyrouth
le pompage de l'eau rétabli américain
philip à vide poursuit ses efforts
diplomatiques explosion d'une bombe en
banlieue parisienne le militants
arméniens qui la manipulent et tué des
documents du groupe orly saisi sur place
le trafic des vacances circulation à peu
près fluide ce soir sur tous les grands
axes routiers
madame monsieur bonsoir
ils étaient une centaine d'enfants qui
partait en colonie de vacances organisée
par la caisse d'allocations familiales
de l'oise une centaine d'enfants de 6 à
15 ans répartis en deux car ils ne sont
que 60 de ce soir avoir atteint sain et
sauf
la colonie la saint cyrienne en savoie
quarante quatre enfants ont péri
carbonisés
la nuit dernière sur l'autoroute du
soleil près de beaune
neuf autres personnes sont morts de la
même façon dans la collision de deux
voitures et des autocars inconscience
vitesse fatalité la route tue chaque
semaine et on s'y habitue presque cette
fois il s'agit du plus grave accident de
la route jamais vu en france et la
plupart des victimes sont des enfants
les faits marcel trillât 4 heures du
matin sur l'autoroute a6 au sud de
beaune le cet amas de tôles broyées
calcinées les sauveteurs n'ont pas
encore achevé d'extraire les cadavres de
53 personnes dont 44 enfants
deux heures plus tôt trois autres quarts
et cette voiture se sont enchevêtrées
ici avant de prendre feu en quelques
secondes ils étaient environ 1h45
à ce moment deux autocars d'une
entreprise de transport de
saint-jean-de-maurienne roule l'un
derrière l'autre dans le sens paris
province à bord une centaine d'enfants
de 6 à 15 ans ils viennent pour la
plupart de crépy en valois ils vont
rejoindre une colonie de vacances
organisée par la direction de l'action
sociale du
appartement de l'oise à aussois en
savoie tout à coup c'est la tragédie
on connaît mieux ce soir les
circonstances de l'accident
la route est glissante la circulation
est dense mais assez fluide
justement la file de voitures qui
précède ralenti le premier quart
français heures tant qu'art allemand le
deuxième quart français vient s'écraser
contre le premier et deux voitures
particulières sont prises en étau
instantanément tout s'enflamme et
d'autres voitures viennent encore
s'écraser dans le brasier
par miracle tous les passagers du
premier quart parviennent à sortir à
temps
ceux du 2e par contre sont pris au piège
la porte avant restant bloqués
seuls quatorze enfants et un moniteur
parviennent à échapper à cet enfer par
la porte arrière et 44 autres deux
moniteurs et les deux chauffeurs moeurs
carbonisé dans l'allée centrale ou sur
leurs sièges les deux voitures broyées
en retirera cinq cadavres eux aussi
carbonisé en tout 53 morts dont 44
enfants l'un des premiers sur les lieux
du drame
le lieutenant colonel bonnet évidente
qui nous est très difficile d'apprécier
la vitesse des 2
véhicule accidenté est fait de quartier
mollet puisque on n'a pas pu récupérer
du fait de me sens ni les disques de
contrôle de l'appareil
par conséquent affirmé que ces cas
roulait trop vite
mon avis est ce que ça avance et des
l'accident un cas allemand qui se promet
un peu en avant de l'accident lui-même à
l'initiative changer tous les enfants et
ça fait ainsi que l'encadrement qui
restait et en est où
ces accidentés jusqu ici chez nous ou
avec la société d'autoroutes nous
des salles pour les réceptionner essaie
de le réconforter du mieux possible dans
un centre aéré de chalon sur saône que
les enfants rescapés ont été rassemblés
c'est là que les responsables de la
colonie de vacances ont dû procéder ou
douloureuses appelle des survivants l'un
d'eux traumatisé par le choc après avoir
échappé aux flammes est resté caché
plusieurs heures durant dans un fourré
au bord de l'autoroute
en fin de matinée les 62 qui ont survécu
sont partis vers ho soit pour de bien
tristes vacances
les enfants venaient de deux localités
de l'oise creil et crépy en valois des
localités où tout le monde se connaît il
était souvent frères et soeurs ou
cousins ce n'est qu'en fin de matinée
que les parents angoissés ont connu le
sort de leurs enfants
estelle gougy depuis 6 heures ce matin à
la mairie de crépy en valois
si l' angoisse latente interminable
l'horreur
il faudra plusieurs heures pour établir
avec certitude la liste des enfants qui
ont trouvé la mort c'est monsieur dupuy
le maire de la ville qui au milieu des
familles viendra un à un les énoncés
ces matériaux
le devoir
m
vous avez combien d'enfants dans le gard
5 ils sont tous sauvés
vous l'avez appris comment cette
nouvelle auto motion arrière m'avait dit
mais les avoir au téléphone hispaniques
et ça fait combien de temps entre le
moment où vous avez su qu'il y avait eu
un accident et le moment où vous allez
suivre aux enfants ont été sauvés
panda les leurs il a su à 6 heures ou le
whisky janvier qui nous l'a dit
c'est est-ce un hasard que vos enfants
soir je crois dans le car une enfant
handicapé seront pratiqués dans les
autres sites web se veut pas une minute
c'est ce qu'on peut vous dire ça
peut-être que je sais qu'ils sont
turbulents qui est remis au creusot
principe une petite épreuve depuis leurs
troupes ait quitté pau
j'essaie à l'école sénat bordeaux ville
en amis qui sont morts dans 15 h caucus
ce soir c'est toute une ville qui est en
deuil
37 enfants de crépy en valois sont morts
17 dans un seul de ces immeubles 7 dans
une seule famille
les familles des victimes se sont
rendues ce soir à beaune à bord d'un
appareil du ministère de la défense qui
les ramènera demain avec les cercueils
des victimes
la colonie de vacances en savoie avait
été organisée à l'attention de ces
enfants souvent défavorisé par le
service d'action sociale du département
après la catastrophe les responsabilités
bien difficile à déterminer font déjà
l'objet d'une controverse est pas une
colonie de vacances organisée par la
caisse d'allocations familiales
c'était une colonie de vacances qui
était connu des services de la caisse
d'allocations familiales et qui étaient
proposés parmi d'autres par les
assistantes sociales aux parents qu'ils
désiraient envoyer leurs enfants en
colonie vous aviez déjà fait appel ou
les assistantes sociales de la caisse
avait déjà proposé cette association de
vacances oui nous travaillons avec cette
association de vacances depuis plusieurs
années dix ans à peu près au moins savez
vous comment ils organisaient le voyage
des enfants
depuis plusieurs années ils organisaient
le voyage des enfants en quarts
et l'écart qui sont partis hier soir ils
étaient venus de saint jean de maurienne
sera l'écart était venue de saint jean
de maurienne
elle était venue à creil simplement
parce que il y avait un assez grand
nombre d'enfants de quoi remplir un car
à creil comme à crépy d'ailleurs vous
saviez que l'écart faisait l'aller et le
retour dans la même journée il ne
faisait pas l'aller et le retour dans la
même journée il était arrivé le matin
ils avaient déposé des enfants il avait
une chambre pas les chauffeurs avaient
une chambre retenus à l'hôtel il devait
repartir le soir
est ce pour mieux en cause
l'organisation même de la colonie de
vacances de l'association de vacances
non je ne pense pas je pense que même
l'association de vacances a pu même ans
assure en s'adressant à une société de
transport bien connu c'est peut-être
aussi un fait humain je ne connais pas
les faits et je ne sais pas où mettre
des responsabilités mais je pense quand
même que tout avait été fait pour que
les enfants soient en sécurité
les pousses du propriétaire des deux
cars affirme de son côté qu'il s'agit
d'une entreprise très sérieuse et qui
est tout à fait en règle
elle estime un vraisemblable l'hypothèse
d'une course poursuite entre les deux
chauffeurs didier regnier vous êtes à
dijon vous étiez sur les lieux de la
catastrophe dès l'aube vous avez pu
recueillir un certain nombre de
témoignages
oui christine c'est une journée bien
triste qui s'achève ici du côté de bonn
sur les bords de cette autoroute où sont
mortes vous l'avez dit 53 personnes dont
44 enfants
un accident qui a plongé la population
dans une stupeur dans une résignation
interrogative ce matin de nombreux
badauds s'étaient groupés sur le petit
pont qui domine l autoroute et tous
semblaient chercher une explication une
raison à cette tragédie
tandis que d'autres dans le village
voisin raconter les événements les
enfants était pieds nus il réclamer leur
sac leurs valises
c'est tout un moniteur accablé confié
qu'il était terrible de perdre la moitié
de ces enfants
un touriste ayant assisté à la scène
évoqué l'impossibilité qu'il y avait à
tenter quoi que ce soit pour sauver les
prisonniers du quart témoignage confirmé
par le chauffeur du deuxième quart j'ai
voulu remonter dit-il dans le véhicule
pour vérifier une dernière fois que tous
les enfants étaient sortis mais je n'ai
pas pu arriver à la hauteur du deuxième
siège tant la fumée était épaisse elle
prenait à la gorge
enfin un dernier témoin qui suivait les
autocars a précisé moi aussi j'ai voulu
aider les blessés les aider pour les
sauver mais cela ressemblait un
chalumeau voilà pour les témoignages
recueillis sur place ce matin
alors où on l enquête se soit est-ce que
l'hypothèse de cette course poursuite
entre les deux chauffeurs de cars est
soutenue par un certain nombre de
témoignages
elle est soutenue par beaucoup de
témoignages christine l'enquète ne fait
que commencer
et pour tout vous avouer elle piétine
effectivement beaucoup de témoins les
premiers témoins survenus sur les lieux
de l'accident ont tous dit que les
autocars rouler très rapidement sans 130
kilomètres à l'heure certains sont même
allés jusqu'à dire qu'ils faisaient une
course et là je dois dire que le le
commandant de gendarmerie du peloton de
chalon que j'ai rencontré tout à l'heure
précise que rien ne permet de dire que
les autocars rouler à plus de 120 130
kilomètres heure pour lui on ne pourra
pas le déterminer la vitesse exacte ne
sera jamais connue dit il car les
disques de contrôle des deux autocars
ont été détruits dans l'incendié ou
dernière précision et en les causes de
cet incendie
l' enquête piétine là aussi le
commandant du peloton de chalon avance
l'hypothèse que le choc aurait servi de
détonateur faisant exploser les
réservoirs d'essence des véhicules merci
il ya gagné le président mitterrand a
dressé en fin de matinée un message de
condoléances aux familles le premier
ministre pierre mauroy est en ce moment
même à beaune pour se recueillir devant
les corps des victimes et conforter
leurs parents ce matin le ministre des
transports charles fiterman s'est rendu
sur les lieux
il a annoncé la constitution d'une
commission denquête il veut aussi
accélérer
les conclusions d'un rapport sur la
réglementation de la circulation des
véhicules lourds
de leur côté edwige avice le ministre de
la jeunesse et des sports et andré henry
ministre du temps libre sont allés
rendre visite aux rescapés de l'étranger
les messages de condoléances à fut à
l'elysée notamment ceux du président
italien pertini et du premier ministre
britannique
enfin syndicats et associations diverses
réagissent demandant une enquête et des
mesures plus strictes pour limiter le
danger sur les routes
le substitut du procureur de la
république de dijon vient d'indiquer
qu'il ouvrira demain
une information pour homicide et
blessures involontaires et défaut de
maîtrise
après la catastrophe de beaune le drame
de la nuit dernière a interrompu ce
matin la circulation sur l'autoroute a6
dans la région il n'ya maintenant
pratiquement plus de traces de
l'accident le trafic a repris
normalement et de façon générale sur
l'ensemble du réseau routier le trafic a
été assez fluide aujourd'hui quand une
perte si vous êtes à rosny sous bois au
centre de la circulation routière le
point ce soir christine comme vous le
dites rien moi presque toutes les
lumières sont éteintes ce qui veut dire
que la situation est fluide sur
l'ensemble du réseau réseau national
routier
malgré l'accident la journée s'est bien
passée il ya eu moins 20 % de trafic par
rapport au 31 juillet dans les dernière
et ce sur ce lac ce autoroutier nord sud
l'accident de marseille a eu un effet
dissuasif sur les automobilistes qui ont
préféré remettre leur départ vers le
midi à demain dans la veille du rhône
les embouteillages ont même été moins
importants qui hier il est triste de
noter que l'embouteillage le plus
important a été de 42 kilomètres qu'il
s'est passé entre tonus est bonne et
qu'il est dû à la curiosité morbide et
autres novices qui ralentissait hauteur
du carnage
actuellement quelques points rouges sont
très localisés à sisteron souillac
pouilly sur loire
à la rochelle on met une heure pour
prendre le bac vers l'île de ré au
perthus du côté espagnol
il y a dix kilomètres de bouchons les
camionneurs bloque la frontière comme
les départs n'ont pas fait le plein
y aller aujourd'hui ici à rosny sous
bois on craint que les vacanciers ne
parte que cette nuit alors un conseil de
bison futé si vous devez vous rendre
dans le sud attendait plutôt donné entre
7 et 11 heures et même dans le début
d'après midi
merci quand une perte suit plusieurs
manifestations d'agriculteurs dans le
sud ouest et dans le languedoc
roussillon n'ont pas trop ralenti la
circulation
il n'y a pas eu d'incident d'autant plus
que certains péages et est gratuit et
qu'il y avait même un narbonne des
distributions gratuites de vin encore à
une semaine de l'élection de l'assemblée
régionale la campagne électorale
commence à s'animer avec la tournée des
ténors du continent
le président du rpr jacques chirac est
le secrétaire général de l'udf jacques
blanc ont tenu un meeting commun hier
soir ajaccio charles fiterman pour le
parti communiste était lui dans la
région de bastia
trois attentats à l'explosif non
revendiquée ont causé à ajaccio la nuit
dernière des dégâts matériels assez
importants délais de grâce pour
l'inscription sur les listes des
élections de prud'hommes le ministère du
travail a décidé de prolonger les
opérations d'enregistrement au delà de
ce samedi qui était en principe la date
limite à l'étranger c'est toujours
l'impasse au liban le cessez le feu
intervenu hier soit après de violents
bombardements a été respectée
aujourd'hui le pompage de l'eau vers
beyrouth ouest interrompues il ya une
semaine a repris cet après midi tandis
que les palestiniens renforcent leur
dispositif de défense gérard ce bague
profitant de ces quelques heures de
calme la population de beyrouth
s'affairent au déblaiement des décombres
après les violents bombardements d' hier
si on fait une vingtaine de morts selon
les experts militaires milles 370 obus
ont été tirés sur la vie dans quelques
heures la recherche d'une solution
politique sera sans doute à ce groupe
ponctué opérations militaires
israéliennes pour accélérer le départ
des combattants palestiniens
cependant cette attitude amène un
durcissement de yasser arafat le leader
de l'ump qui la nuit dernière a pris la
décision de consolider les défenses de
beyrouth
monsieur yasser arafat a envoyé
également des messages pour souligner la
gravité de la situation
un monsieur leonid brejnev françois
mitterrand fidel castro le roi d'arabie
saoudite et le secrétaire général des
nations unies israël entrebâillée son
blocus en permettant le pompage de l'eau
mais pour la sixième journée consécutive
ni électricité ni vivres commence à
s'animer avec la tournée des ténors du
continent
le président du rpr jacques chirac est
le secrétaire général de l'udf jacques
blanc ont tenu un meeting commun hier
soir à ajaccio charles fiterman pour le
parti communiste était lui dans la
région de bastia
trois attentats à l'explosif non
revendiquée ont causé ajaccio la nuit
dernière des dégâts matériels assez
importants délais de grâce pour
l'inscription sur les listes des
élections de prud'hommes le ministère du
travail a décidé de prolonger les
opérations d'enregistrement au delà de
ce samedi qui était en principe la date
limite à l'étranger c'est toujours
l'impasse au liban le cessez-le-feu
intervenu hier soir après de violents
bombardements a été respectée
aujourd'hui le pompage de l'eau vers
beyrouth ouest interrompues il ya une
semaine a repris cet après midi tandis
que les palestiniens renforcent leur
dispositif de défense gérard ce bague
profitant de ces quelques heures de
calme la population de beyrouth
s'affairent au déblaiement des décombres
après les violents bombardements
d'hyères qui ont fait une vingtaine de
morts selon les experts militaires
milles 370 obus ont été tirés sur la vie
dans quelques heures la recherche d'une
solution politique sera sans doute à
nouveau conclue et opérations militaires
israéliennes pour accélérer le départ
des combattants palestiniens dans cette
attitude amène un durcissement de yasser
arafat le leader selon el pais qui la
nuit dernière a pris la décision de
consolider les défenses de beyrouth
monsieur yasser arafat a envoyé
également des messages pour souligner la
gravité de la situation à messieurs
leonid brejnev françois mitterrand fidel
castro le roi d'arabie saoudite et le
secrétaire général des nations unies
israël entrebâillée son blocus en
permettant le pompage de l'eau mais pour
la sixième journée consécutive
ni électricité ni vivre la vie dans le
réduit palestine aux progressistes est
toujours aussi difficile
dans les hôpitaux la situation devient
préoccupante manque de médicaments et de
plasma sanguin la croix-rouge s'inquiète
surtout des possibilités d'épidémie on
signale des cas de gastro entérite et de
galles
sur le plan diplomatique la confusion
règne le négociateur américain philip
aviv a une nouvelle fois rencontré
aujourd'hui le président libanais et son
premier ministre qui souhaite avant tout
la levée du blocus israélien
philippe habib a en tout cas obtenu ce
matin vous le savez la reprise du
pompage de l'eau indispensable à la
survie de la population
philippe abîme depuis des semaines fait
la navette entre les différentes parties
en cause
pour éviter le pire et pour tenter
d'obtenir un compromis
c'est lui qui de jour en jour rétabli
vaille que vaille le cessez le feu
l'homme qui tient ainsi entre les mains
les filles fragiles d'un règlement est
un diplomate hors du commun
son portrait jean marc guillou si de
londres à damas de jérusalem à beyrouth
aucune des allées et venues de ce petit
homme rond ne doivent échapper aux
caméras
c'est parce que la mission de philippe
habib envoyé spécial du président des
états unis
ici avec le premier ministre et le
président libanais c'est parce que sa
mission est d'empêcher le siège de
beyrouth de tourner au massacre
deuxième objectif du médiateur américain
obtenir le départ du liban de toutes les
forces libanaises
aux termes d'un cessez-le-feu durable
mais parce que comme israël les états
unis n'ont pas de contact officiel avec
l'ol paie les négociations sont toujours
indirects c'est donc par le truchement
d'une multitude d'intermédiaires arabe
libanais surtout que cet américain fils
d'épicier libanais lui même est né dans
un quartier juif de new york sondent les
intentions de l'ol paie et s'efforce
ensuite de trouver un compromis avec ses
interlocuteurs israéliens comme ici avec
isaac shamir un mélange de jovialité de
franc-parler un sens du concret qui
écarte volontiers le protocole philippe
abeba dit-on la confiance personnelle de
ronald reagan et une grande liberté de
manoeuvre
il ne parle jamais aux journalistes et
se déplacent sans fanfare pendant sa
mission liban philippe rabit ben
toujours consultant dans le secteur
privé n'a pas le droit à d'autres
salaire que sa retraite de diplomates de
carrière
il touche une indemnité de 80 dollars
par jour 560 francs explosion cet après
midi à l'aéroport de munich près du
guichet d'embarquement de la compagnie
israélienne el al
sept personnes ont été blessées dont
trois grièvement
l'engin explosif aurait été placée dans
la valise d'un passagers embarquant sur
l'avion israélien
la fin d'une guerre la guerre des
malouines le retour à la tradition celle
de l' empire britannique
les cérémonies marquant dans l'archipel
rétablissement de l'ordre normal de la
vie insulaire avait comme il se doit une
allure très britannique gerard ce bac
les falkland ont véritablement retrouvé
la tradition britannique c'est le signe
inéluctable du retour à la souveraineté
de londres sur l'archipel
et l'on sait combien les anglais sont à
chercher a répliqué me paraître comme
parfois des juges
le haut commissaire britannique sur aix
en arborant son bicorne à plumes a
présidé à l'ouverture du conseil
législatif à force en six personnes
représentent les 1800 habitants de
l'archipel
le gouverneur après avoir salué les
soldats qui ont participé à la
libération va pouvoir maintenant
s'occuper des dégâts écologiques
provoqués par la guerre
monsieur très étrange le conservateur de
nul lui a fait part de ses
préoccupations concernant la population
de pingouins il y en aurait plusieurs
millions ainsi que des albatros quelques
baleines des dauphins et d'autres
variétés d'animaux à poils et à plumes
la vidéo du monde britannique qu une
explosion dans un pavillon de banlieue a
gagné la nuit dernière confirme les
menaces des terroristes arméniens du
groupe orly
pierre gouloumes y ans s'est tué en
manipulant une bombe de sa fabrication
dans un pavillon appartenant à des amis
corses l'intérieur du logement été
soufflées par la déflagration
mais son frère qui était au
rez-de-chaussée et un deuil interrogé
par les policiers de la brigade
criminelle il reste muet il était au
liban il y a dix jours des documents
niveau poorly ont été trouvés sur place
les deux frères naturalisé français sont
nés au proche orient
le groupe orly je vous le rappelle a
revendiqué deux des attentats commis la
semaine dernière à paris et les
policiers pourraient tenir maintenant la
première piste sérieuse sur ce groupe
mystérieux et ses racines au proche
orient
le meurtrier du gardien de la paix a
battu hier en plein centre de nantes a
été arrêté
la nuit dernière il s'agit d'un
malfaiteur qui a bénéficié d'une remise
de peine après une condamnation à 15 ans
de réclusion criminelle et différents
syndicats de policiers protestent et
réclament davantage de fermeté dans la
lutte contre la criminalité
une cérémonie à la mémoire du gardien de
la paix s'est déroulée cet après-midi
sur les lieux de la fusillade pour aérer
cette actualité bien lourde
une histoire l'histoire d'une femme qui
exerce un métier peu courant à l'entrée
des ports pour réglementer le trafic
dans les sémaphores travail des
personnages que l'on ne voit jamais des
aiguilleurs des bateaux en quelque sorte
ils sont plusieurs centaines doute au
long du littoral
parmi eux une seule femme jean claude
rigaud et gérard deerlijk l'ont
rencontré
quatre dans la région d tél on la
connaît bien la josiane les marins
pêcheurs comme les plaisanciers de l'été
la voix de cette jeune femme de 33 ans
ils ont entendu retentir dans le haut
parleur de leur radio de bord
à chaque fois qu'ils ont abordé le
chenal du port
alors quoi consiste votre travail
consiste à surveiller des bandes sabat
may et suivant le passage que je trouve
je prends des repères qui sont juste sur
le balcon et je guide les bateaux après
dans le passage que j'ai trouvé que
parce que la pâte est difficile c'est la
pensée politicienne non mais il ya des
bonnes soeurs qui se déplacent qu'il
faut les surveiller encore à gauche
josiane peiné a été forte étonné que
l'on s'intéresse à elle elle fait son
travail de sémaphoriste un travail qui
implique jour et nuit vigilance coup
d'oeil esprit de décision sans avoir
pour cela l'impression qu'elle est sa
petite fille de 10 ans et quoi que ce
soit d'extraordinaire
pourtant au pays des tales qui en a vu
bien d'autres
on n'hésite pas à dire elle a eu du cran
la josiane après son malheur j'ai
commencé ce travail à deux ans mais je
tenais enfin j'étais avec mon mari au
sémaphore il ya une douzaine d'années il
ya douze ans passés de février
malheureusement il est tombé malade
ensuite il est décédé il ya la mairie
d'etel ils ont été en faisons pour eux
j'étais capable de tenir le sémaphore
étant donné j'avais un brevet de radio
que je savais comment surveiller les
bonnes âmes je savais aussi guidé les
bateaux et on m'a gardé ses merveilles
idf mais ce n'est pas un travail trop
haut trop dur pour une femme non non
j'ai enfin il faut aimer son travail je
pense que lorsqu'on aime son travail va
rien et difficile mais l'hiver vous ne
vous sentez pas isolé l'été savoir vous
avez des vacanciers mais l'hiver non
alors en hiver je prends mes vacances
chalain vers les autres josiane peiné
une femme à laquelle les propriétaires
de navires n'hésite pas à confier leur
capital de travail et la sécurité de
leurs équipages dans la brume et des
tempêtes rendent les retours difficiles
où un certain ses gestes et ses
manoeuvres
elle les fait invariablement plusieurs
dizaines de fois en 24 heures
son salaire 3800 francs par an
le tour de france à la voile le voilier
le havre a remporté hier la 14e étape la
rochelle royan et se rapproche de
marseille au classement général c'est à
deauville qu aura lieu le tiercé de
demain les pronostics de pierrette brès
vous les voyez sur votre écran le 13 le
3 le 8 le 7 le dise le 2 et le 11 le
temps maintenant on parlait hier de
sécheresse et les avait décelé vous avez
réussi à faire pleuvoir
oui la plus il a même presque trop plus
par endroits la preuve dans les
départements de l'hérault et du gard qui
étaient victimes de la sécheresse depuis
plusieurs semaines eh bien il a plu très
très fort des pluies d'une intensité
exceptionnelle puisque paraît-il on n'en
avait pas vu de semblable depuis 62 ans
et ses pluies exceptionnelles ont fait
des victimes puisque 500 brebis ont été
foudroyées toujours dans ces régions
alors pour demain et bien la météo
nationale prévoit une akali du mauvais
temps mais ça ne durera pas longtemps
demain matin donc de la brume un peu
partout encore un peu de pluie au bord
de la manche et sur les alpes mais ça ne
durera pas et ailleurs et l'après midi
donc est bien assez beau temps partout
avec tout de même davantage de nuages
sur la bretagne la normandie le nord et
jusqu'à l'alsace
et puis dans la soirée et bien retour du
mauvais temps par le sud ouest ce qui
amènera des nuages et des orages sur les
pyrénées et le sud du massif central
les températures demain à l'exception de
la manche et de la mer du nord à des
bords de la manche et la mer du nord où
il n'y aura pas de changement
edel va faire un petit peu plus chaud
une moyenne de deux degrés de plus par
rapport à aujourd'hui
ce qui donnera des maxima à 30 degrés
dans la région de perpignan et de
marseille et en corse
demain nous serons le dimanche 1er août
le ciel a donc décidé de faire un petit
effort pour cela que hier ce nouveau
mois un effort aussi pour les alphonse
et pour les suisses dont ce sera la fête
nationale à 23h15 jean claude renaud
vous présentera notre dernier journal
demain en can 2010 avec philippe labro
merci d'avoir suivi cette édition je
vous retrouverai demain à 20 heures
bonne soirée